my mom and I created an account which
was very hard to create which is kind of
weird Liz hurls a pretty big accusation
at Big Ed like you can't write this
stuff Big Ed and Liz bring their on and
off again relationship drama to part one
of the 90 Day Fiance happily ever after
tell-all but Liz you've never been alone
you've always been with a guy in this
man you've always been in toxic sick
relationships
but it gets even Messier when Ed's
ex-fiance Rose drops in from the
Philippines with a bombshell it has Ed
messaged you or spoken to you the last
couple months
foreign
episode Liz and Ed all smiled sitting
side by side kind of interesting body
language there considering Ed straight
up told Liz he wasn't ready to marry her
during the season finale right now
um I can't give you an answer on
marriage I'm not ready to marry anyone
so when Ed and Liz reveal the status of
their relationship the cast is pretty
shocked we're still together we're
engaged but we're not living together
another stunning moment when Ed admitted
he kicked Liz out when she had nowhere
to go she wound up couch surfing while
trying to find her own place
for doing that
okay well first of all you don't know
the situation
we were fighting every day
I begged her Liz it's not working please
move out
I will help you in any way again and she
wouldn't
well Liz finally got her own place and
she's got an arrangement with Ed that
she says Works staying at his home every
other night Ed doubled down on all of
that adding that even when they're
married he wants separate bedrooms
that's not love no yeah it's not love no
that's weird to me yeah that's really
sad but the heat gets turned all the way
up when Ed claims that Liz threatened to
leave him if he didn't marry her in two
weeks I said you're either all in trying
to make this relationship work
I'm gonna go be with other guys I'm
putting myself back on the market
threaten me like I'm gonna go and sleep
around that's you because you dumped me
I'm single so evil please if that's what
you want don't threaten me commit
yourself don't threaten me don't
threaten me don't live your single life
you've never been alone you've always
been with a guy you've always been in
toxic sick relationships that's the
awful thing to say it's the truth and
then they go from arguing over jealousy
because he's jealous I'm not
Liz are you jealous
no oh my God are you kidding me to Liz
revealing she caught Ed on a dating app
for Asian women after he made her move
out let's back up again when we got
there a year and a half old my mom and I
created an account which was very hard
to create which is kind of weird but
some fans believe it because when we
first met Ed on 90 Day Fiance he was
with his much younger than fiance Rose
who was from the Philippines
three hours you and your mom set up a
fake account
an hour after I left his house we
checked again the next day and he was
active three hours prior to that I want
I want to see the receipts that was a
year and a half old website speaking of
Rose Sean asked Ed if he's still in
contact with her I may have I don't I
don't remember
you may how are you not it's a yes or no
I don't know I don't know if I was or
not
nothing like a surprise Cameo from Rose
herself to refresh Ed's memory
it has ADD messaged you or spoken to you
the last couple months
[Music]
yeah in a preview of part two of this
hello airing January 8th it looks like
Ed and Liz's relationship is going to
head even further downhill you want me
to be on your side when you're I want
you to try to be honest
about how I feel it's about how are you
feeling why do you keep coming back
[Music]
foreign